[Music]
German soldiers turnout for morning roll
call and sing the Marseillaise that's
nothing unusual at the Robert Schumann
barracks near the French border
corporal Marais has been serving in the
franco-german Brigade for four years now
he and the other officers know how
important it is for nations to work
together for these soldiers Europe is
part of their daily lives every day they
really feel they are Europeans singing
both national anthems is only one of the
features unique to this brigade every
day brings special challenges they have
the language barrier and always will we
have German soldiers who don't speak
French and vice-versa they have to build
bridges and they always have to remember
that something might not have been
understood during weapons training for
example one instructor explains and the
other translates marais originally comes
from Berlin he's just signed up for
another four years with the brigade he
has no trouble with the rifle drills we
have to learn to handle the French arms
and that means practice and the French
instruct us because they're French arms
the military routines of the two
countries have no differences as the
instructor explains this is a good
example this kind of thing happens here
every day in training we show each other
our equipment so everyone has a chance
to try it out the commanding officers
get ready to visit the troops they're
busy with a transport exercise the
officers communicate in English the
official language of NATO
everyone here speaks it we have no
special reports concerning incidents and
so on they are currently on their
mission English was also the working
language for the six months the
battalion was stationed in Lithuania for
NATO that was the high point of marae's
service to date he keeps some photos of
Lithuania on his cell phone on the road
to Strasbourg and France
another of the brigades bases supplies
where the troops are shuttled back and
forth across the River Rhine German and
French military traditions do differ
however the Germans are very progressive
a 21st century management style but the
French are still very military in
everything they do the forest camp is
closely guarded the commanding officer
turns up to inspect the exercise as a
German officer he serves in a military
force whose every mission has to be
approved by the Bundestag but his French
counterparts can be deployed on direct
orders from the French president this
difference can have political
ramifications
I know who pame is for me I see a
European military as a glimpse of the
future I think for many things it's
possible and necessary to work them out
in a political process if you ask us as
the military will say sure we can do it
overnight after all we've been doing it
for 30 years
the brigade has started traditions of
its own built a measure of confidence
created their own uniforms and songs
with verses in two languages its members
share a common spirit perhaps setting an
example for European military forces of
the future